well so you know i'm bald and gray for a
reason right from all the mistakes that
i made when i was running companies
and so you know it's through those
experiences you build up
hopefully patterns that you learn from
welcome to 20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with low metec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford we are in stanford's business
school
welcome robert eric siegel a lecturer in
management at the stanford graduate
school of business
he teaches five different courses on
strategy innovation finance and product
management
he is also a general partner at exceed
capital and a venture partner at piva
along with holding executive positions
in various startups and enterprises
he is the co-inventor of four patents
and served as lead researcher for andy
grove's best-selling book
only the paranoid survive he has a new
book coming out later this year on how
leading companies are combining the best
of digital
and physical in products and solutions
rob siegel welcome to 20 minute leaders
i'm so honored to have you here
thank you so much it's a pleasure to be
here we're going to have so much fun in
these 20 minutes
this is one of those times where i say i
should have called this 30 minute
leaders
i don't know why i wrote down 20 in the
initial draft but but here we are
rob i would love to talk about your
journey i want to talk about your
passion for teaching
in your lecture at stanford graduate
school of business
by far the best business school in the
world and i have no bias at all of
course
but beyond that you're incredibly active
in the in the tech ecosystem both as a
partner
in venture capital funds as an investor
as a board member as an entrepreneur
yourself
also being in corporates being a senior
product manager at intel moving on to
to ge and being a general manager for
350 million dollar
uh you know annual revenue line and your
research today is just fascinating on
thinking more critically about the
ecosystem and how do companies
work through their you know financial
life cycles and leverage
digital and physical uh you know the
integration of goods for customers
this is as much as i'm going to talk for
this whole discussion rob
first of all take me all the way back to
you know growing up you go to stanford
gsb
do you is this the trajectory you want
to have you want to
one day be a lecturer teaching some of
the most amazing courses that i can
think of
are you i had no idea where my journey
was going to be you know i grew up in
southern california
uh moved the bay area the first time as
an undergrad at university of california
berkeley
uh was planning on studying engineering
was a horrible engine
was just truly awful i think no it
wasn't that i was a horrible engineer it
was worse than that
i was average so i became a political
science major
and went to work as an undergrad for a
software company at the age of 17 and so
i've been in tech
now for over 35 years my career was a
kind of a series of random walks i ended
up just opportunities presented
themselves
i was with that software company for six
years i then went to stanford
i was then at intel uh then i started a
company that got acquired by kodak
then went to another startup that was
spun out of the engineering school at
stanford that got bought by sony
then i joined ge which was a complete
accident
i moved back to southern california and
then moved back
up here 14 years ago when i became a
slimy scum-sucking venture capitalist
and so my career has kind of been a walk
of large and small
investing side operating side the
teaching kind of just happened
i started collaborating with one of my
mentors robert bergelman
back about 17 18 years ago we started
teaching a few cases together
that we wrote a couple of papers and
soon i was you know basically showing up
randomly to basically all of the
sessions in one of his courses
and so then i formally joined the
faculty a decade ago as a lecturer
and then about seven years ago picked up
a second course and then a third course
and then a fourth horse
and it just kind of just grew from there
so i i can't say that it was planned
each step made sense at a moment in time
but i never anticipated that i would be
here at this point
you're coming to stanford campus you're
standing in front of dozens of of
business school students some of the
brightest people in the world people
that have done
incredible things and they're destined
to do even more incredible things later
on and you're there at the forefront
that
you know as an educator but also you
know personally really sharing with them
your experiences but how they can you
know even grow as entrepreneurs and
business people
what is that like what is that like
being a lecturer in stanford business
school what is that responsibility and
why do you love it so much so
it's an interesting thing because when
i'm up in front of the classroom
you know my job is to serve the students
and i'm fundamentally just an older
version of them when i did my graduate
work danford i would
argue that i was an undifferentiated
student in my cohort
from the class of 94 the gsb and so my
responsibility
when i'm up there is to kind of help
coach and guide them both on whatever
topic we're studying be it strategy or
product management or finance
but perhaps you know even more
importantly to
you know guide them to being a stanford
leader what are the responsibilities
that come with that because you know we
got very lucky
all of us who got to go to stanford or
you know seven and a half billion people
on the planet on a rock hurtling through
space and we get to hang out at this
place
and and so my hope is that we teach them
both not only
you know great skills that will allow
them to hopefully achieve their dreams
but also kind of what is what comes with
that and how should they be thinking
more broadly about the implications of
what they do
and i would say that you know it it's
great it's awesome when i teach
in front of the classroom when hopefully
we'll get back in the classroom soon
it's like teaching at the united nations
you see men and women from all over the
world from
a variety of backgrounds every continent
is represented every last name
is represented and it's a real joy to
keep up with that youth and that energy
and that fresh perspective that they can
often bring right i can't even imagine
how exhilarating it must feel to
both teach the things that you're so
passionate about at the same time know
that
every year you're getting a new group of
students all of them are
getting knowledge from me but also
giving you knowledge from their
experiences and i
i'm first i'm incredibly excited for
hopefully one day to take you up
have the opportunity to sit in front of
you in one of those in one of those
classes but
but really i can i can just feel the
excitement coming from you now tell me a
little bit about your involvement
you know on the vc side so you're in one
hand you're a thinker
in the tech ecosystem another one you
then you go into the hands down and you
dig deep into actually what's happening
on the ground level
how did those two things balance each
other
well so you know i'm bald and gray for a
reason right from all the mistakes that
i made when i was running companies
and so you know it's through those
experiences you build up
hopefully patterns that you learn from
and i got lucky enough to join a venture
capital from 14 years ago when i went to
exceed
and i had been at intel capital or what
was the predecessor of intel when i
graduated from stanford
we were called corporate business
development in those days so the
investing side kind of goes hand in hand
with the entrepreneurial and operation
side of trying to
come up with something new and scale of
business what i love about
venture today is that it allows me to
kind of always stay fresh and what's on
the forefront
of what's coming 5 10 15 years down the
road and i work at stanford which also
allows me to work with
global fortune 50 companies uh again
from all over the world
you get to kind of see both how you you
know run something at scale which is a
skill set that's hard and very
under-appreciated especially in silicon
valley but also trying to be thinking
about what's coming next
and how are we people going to have to
grow any change involved and
from how you develop products to how you
organize companies to even the
leadership skills that are required to
be successful
in a world that increasingly blends
digital and physical
have those skills shifted you know since
you've been thinking about this
critically are you seeing
like really dramatic shifts obviously
you know with with covert and with the
world changing around us
there must be significant changes that
we have to make as leaders
in our relative organizations right
yeah i would say that if we go back
maybe even 10
15 years you know you have this these
two different worlds of what i'll call
the digital world in the physical world
you know companies that are
predicated here in silicon valley
especially in the last 10 15 years the
software companies the facebooks the
googles et cetera
there's a mindset like a horizontal
mindset of building platforms
and and data becomes you know your
barrier to entry to other organizations
and we talk about marketplaces
and network effects but the physical
world is still real
the physical world you know where we buy
cars and we eat food and we go on
vacations and all these other things
that we do and that's not going to
change
and but you know the companies that
built real things that took a set of
skill sets and competencies and what
we're seeing now increasingly
is a lot of product like almost every
product is increasingly connected
and so you'll have a digital and a
physical component and we're also seeing
the digital
companies go into some of these physical
worlds and a great example might be
how autonomous vehicles are you know
coming into existence
and how silicon valley's been very
active in that
the thing about going into these new
types of markets and these new types of
products is
leaders need to actually have both skill
sets and competencies of digital and
physical
you know we i teach a course with jeff
emil my old boss from ge
called systems leadership and it's the
idea you really need to understand
inside of your organization how are
different functions interacting
how's your company interacting with
what's in its ecosystem who's under
stress and pressure and why
whereas in the old days you could kind
of be a real deep expert domain on one
thing and
i don't think that's going to work over
the next decade the leaders
that we're seeing come into you know our
classes at stanford and that we're able
to study
you see the leaders are able to you know
know how to manage small
and large you can't just be high i want
to be the innovators the innovation
person
or hey i just want to be the operations
person you have to know how to do both
and so you're really trying to see
leaders uh have to develop skill sets
that really weren't
uh required before in order to bring
your organization to the next level
right so what's really really about that
shift and the integration between the
digital and the physical project this is
something that
somehow i didn't really get to
acknowledge until i i started reading
your research
and it makes perfect sense because on
one hand you know saying this early
stage
all these early stage startups and
reading market reasons you know software
is eating the world and
you know we go now through our academic
studies and our
network and we say yes everything is
software everything is digital we're
forgetting about the physical space
but but it's not that case right the
case is that it's actually just
augmenting
the way that we're interacting with our
physical products well
there was there was some truth to what
mark wrote when he wrote software's
eating the world and by the way it's a
very catchy phrase and people repeat it
over and over again
um you know because everything is
connected and so that notion of
how software enables you to have ongoing
relationships with your customers as
opposed to selling a product once and
then being done with it
but the other side of it is you know
mark wrote another blog post in the last
couple of years about the importance of
building things
and you know we we are three-dimensional
creatures who live in a
three-dimensional world
so even though you and i are doing this
you know over zoom uh
you know when education comes back when
covet is over it'll be about and
it'll be about the ability for us to be
somewhat in person and some doing this
and all you i think even in the
classroom we will be combining the way
that we use the technologies for how we
teach you look at companies let me take
an
existing establishment let's look at
target the american retailer
you know a big chunk of their business
is that combination of digital and
physical they
think and they use data to not only how
do they sell you things online but how
do they design their stores
what's the drive up experience where you
order online and then go to the store
and pick up
conversely we can think of a disrupter
let's look at 23andme
and which skis company which is
basically using data basically software
and spit
to develop therapeutics right and she's
actually having to figure out how she
will develop drugs and partner with gsk
and then get them manufactured and
distributed so even though it starts
with a digital dna in a digital
foundation
it actually gets into the physical world
and these types of leaders you know
brian cornell who runs target
and wojiski who runs 23andme these are
the type of people who have to be able
to know how
to do both uh you can even think of
someone like katrina lake who was with
in our class a couple of weeks ago the
ceo of stitch fix
you know sure she's sending me clothes
in fact i think i bought this shirt on
stitch fix
but the data science behind it is what
allows you know
her organization to not only give me
better clothes that i might want but to
understand why i do buy things and why i
don't buy things
and then design better physical clothes
based upon the input i give
in ways that other clothing
manufacturers will never be able to
and it's the software it's the digital
that allows her company to have an
ongoing conversation with me
i'm incredibly excited about where we're
headed i think that now this
understanding of this integration and
how it's not a zero-sum game everything
that we do
has a piece that will be augmented
through the physical world augmented
through the digital world
world and the right entrepreneurs the
right leaders that are able to to
be open-minded about the different ways
of interactivity and bring in the right
people i'm extremely excited about that
you also have some really fascinating
thoughts about this idea of
the financial life cycle of the company
and we're seeing you know a bunch of
different models that
that companies are are using you know i
think that one of the
biggest trends that we've seen over the
past decade or so both in silicon valley
and where i'm from in tel aviv
this proliferation of funding and and
this consideration okay when is it right
to become profitable when is it right
to to have that step and when is it even
relevant so i'd love to hear some of
your thoughts on this
so there's several things that you
highlighted there that are worth
considering so
the notion of when does a company become
profitable we were talking before this
right
patrick hollis and the ceo of strike
when he was in our class
talked about sometimes you want to delay
profitability and why
well in patcher's example on strike they
were
using the opportunity to gather more and
more and more data
and the ability to kind of expand
because of network effects
that being profitable was not the figure
of merit that would lead to the best
outcome for the organization so
being profitable was less important than
them spreading their footprint but the
thing leaders have to deal with today in
a world of low low interest rates when
you have so much
capital coming into you know uh venture
and the like for for entrepreneurs is
how do they think about the capital they
raise and then of course how do they
deploy it
and so the life cycle of an organization
as a ceo you have to be thinking in the
early stages
you know what's the impact of the
investors motivations versus how i want
to build the company
when you go to a growth stage how do you
think about what your partners are
looking for
and then at the time that you have a
liquidity event also what are the
competencies and what are the things
looking for in the public markets or the
like
and it's all changing right you know we
see what the proliferation of spax which
there's a bubble
nature to what's happening with spax
right now we need to be cognizant of
but look at the number of companies that
are using that as a tool to get
liquidity and to go public
to raise capital to continue to growth
and
grow fund the growth of their business
but also to be thinking about how are
they long-term going to be able to
create liquidity for their investors and
for their employees so i i would argue
that the change that's happening right
now
in the funding life cycle of
organizations is as dynamic as a time as
i've ever seen
and what we're seeing is actually more
and more and more capital
going to fewer and fewer and fewer
companies
and that's actually a really interesting
dynamic because
then you get into questions of winner
take all you get into questions of
winner take most
how will that you know get to
geopolitical issues that i would argue
business leaders
didn't have to deal with before not only
do you have like
you know kind of the national treasures
that countries need to look out for we
see that kind of between the us and
china
but how does that create conflict
between countries
and then by the same token look at how
communication and collaboration tools
are going to continue to if you will
allow organizations and people from all
over the world
to continue to work together in ways
that never could have been done before i
mean i'm teaching people
literally from all over the world when
they are and all over the world i did
programs from moscow this week
i've done programs for for companies in
sao paulo and rio de janeiro and jakarta
so you know leaders need to be thinking
about all of these things about how
you're going to have
these kind of conflicting forces and the
financial forces that we started this
question with
are actually driving a lot of the
behaviors and kind of what a leader is
able to do
with her or his company i just love this
rob one of the things that i'm i get so
excited particularly
a conversation like this is just show me
how much i don't know and making me so
deeply curious
about about learning about so many of
the things that you that you're
mentioning so just thank you
for for sharing all this with me and for
spending your so such
a precious time with me i i really
appreciate it and we have just a few
minutes left but what i'm really excited
to talk to you about is
your passion your energy is infectious
and i need to know the secret sauce
when you wake up in the morning what are
you so excited about what how how are
you so excited
about what you're talking about because
i want to have that excitement
okay caffeine all right so caffeine's a
big help so
coffee is what kind of makes all this go
uh
broadly speaking i'm 50 about to be 53
years old
and you know i was kind of a late
bloomer in my career and so i i
kind of get my energy professionally
from you know i'm at a phase in my life
my role is to serve others right serve
my students
serve the large organizations that i
work with serve my wife and my children
and so it's actually i found that to be
very liberating that my job is to help
other people achieve their goals
and so for me when i get out of bed
every morning it's like what am i going
to get to do today who am i going to get
to work with who am i going to get to
support am i going to get to teach
finance am i going to get to teach
product management
am i going to get to teach strategy and
and i'm lucky you know you and you and i
are lucky we got lucky we
got to go to this place and you know
just kind of every day i'm
trying to be grateful for that and not
get caught up in all of the
normal ups and downs of life i mean i'm
really tired
of being in my home office i don't know
about you but sometimes this place is
awesome and sometimes it's my jail
and i'm an introvert like i hate people
like you know
at the end of the day i'm exhausted but
i at this point in time
i miss people i miss being in the
classroom with my students i miss seeing
them smile and laugh and i miss
making them angry and i miss you know
confusing them and all those things that
come with being a teacher
um but like when it happens it's like
it's magic when you
see a student get something it's just
like you see the light bulb go off and
it's like yeah i did my job today i
helped somebody learn something that's
what i'm supposed to do
i love that if there was one thing you
could tell you know
students whether they're 18 years old or
40 years old but
learners people that love learning what
would it be because your whole career i
think spans around this idea of
being curious being innovative being
intuitive and trying to understand the
bigger and smaller
you know ecosystems and and what drives
what so as a lifelong learner that i
aspire to be
what what is what is something that you
think that i can take with me
uh you know it can be general it can be
specific that you would
take out from your career i know it's
such an easy question but
it's the opposite of easy you because
you asked me for one thing i would say i
mean i'm not gonna answer the question
you ask i'm gonna answer the question i
want to answer
which is the the key messages i would
say it's hard right
everything we go through it's hard it's
not easy like don't read tech crunch
tech crunches are on the same 19 people
and you think that's how the universe is
supposed to be that's not what it's like
for most people
number two it's all going to be okay
right if you're above ground it's all
going to be okay right
you know we all get there um third
getting old is a choice and i'm not
talking about the physically getting old
right you know because my body doesn't
you know can't do what it used to be
able to do um but you know the the
notion of
if you choose to stop learning that's a
choice
the one thing in the universe we control
is what we see in the mirror in the
morning when we're
brushing our teeth or putting on our
makeup or shaving and so the ability to
want to learn new things and the ability
to challenge ourselves and to push
ourselves into
our zone of discomfort that's a choice
we make and so i would
you know encourage people to you know
don't be afraid to molt your skin
every five to ten years and to try
something new and yeah maybe you won't
be as good as you were
uh as at the old thing but that's okay
because you'll master a new skill over
time
rob i'm completely inspired thank you so
much for spending this precious time
with me i so appreciate it
now now the really the hardest question
which is three words that you would
choose to describe yourself or if i
would ask any of your students
sitting dead center front row in your
gsb classes
how would they describe rob segal
uh three words okay someone's going to
say energetic
i can bind uh probably someone's going
to say
short because like i'm five six on a
warm day on a warm day
uh and bald like you know it's kind of
the golden dome that's kind of part of
the trademark
and so you know i would i i would say
that
you know those are the three words that
come to mind rob
thank you so so much stay safe and stay
healthy and i can't wait to see you
around campus
thank you very much for having me